hey guys welcome back to the as an
Indian podcast so today we're gonna talk
about some updates recently we got some
new toys toys we had some sponsor drama
drama
and we finished some things that needed
finishing desperately I'm trying to like
say this is kind of the main topic we're
gonna get into today is like the
blessing and curse of real-time feedback
which is something that is a very
prominent part of our jobs
yeah problem - part of our jobs but also
prominent parts of like anyone's life
yeah anyone who has Instagram account or
a Facebook account or anything I mean
even some some types of jobs are like
all data crunched and everything now I
think it's kind of interesting I don't
know and then if we have time we'll play
a game we'll see how long it takes let's
talk about all this stuff exciting okay
so so new new toys oh geez we're gonna
be getting to this later I'm holding up
my favorite new toy right now so people
who are watching the YouTube video it'll
be a thing of the week later but the
other thing that we got is we finally
got Kailyn a 4k editing computer bingo
bingo it was gonna be awesome it was
gonna be big it was gonna be powerful
and it was it's also so loud yeah it was
super loud it had like six fans and they
ran at full speed constantly constantly
I mean like to the point where editing
was difficult because I need to I need
to be able to see is the music too loud
our voice is loud enough what's the
relationship between these different
sounds and sometimes it's a subtle
difference between it being right and
wrong and the whole reason I mean I did
think about buying all the parts and
assembling it myself but we're trying to
get really efficient with our time the
one thing in our life that we don't have
is time and I was like okay you know
what I'm gonna find a computer that has
all the specs that I want that has good
ratings and I'm just gonna get that and
that's gonna save us time I was wrong oh
no I think it's still saved
dahye that save time compared to you
building a computer from scratch yeah
somewhat I mean but like you know
dealing with troubleshooting and sending
it back and everything because at first
I didn't know what was wrong with it I
was like why is it so loud is it just we
also didn't know if it was like an error
if it was supposed to be that way yeah
and also like I was used to building the
computer from like the like the basic
computer that only has like like a
normal amount of fans and like very
basic considerations but since this is a
high-powered computer that has a lot of
heat being generated in it it has liquid
cooling it has a lot of ventilation a
lot of fans but the fans were hooked up
just to like basically a power splitter
and they were just being plugged in to
full power and they're running all the
time they weren't like being
intelligently controlled by yeah the
computer based on the temperature of the
computer yeah so that was that was
something that happened I don't know
it's just it's just another thing that
we're learning you know we're continuing
to grow or continuing to experiment with
things and computers yeah I think that's
something that we learned it's something
that I learned because I and I do know
about what goes into a computer and I
did know that fans are concerned I
didn't know what to look for when I was
buying a computer and like make sure
that it had variable-speed fans for a
computer of this type I don't know I
still think that we're learning I'm kind
of like chalk it up to a learning
experience and make positive from it
yeah it's been like a week of computer
drama and back and forth with the
company yeah speaking of back and forth
with companies and drama
so sponsors recently uh yeah this is
gonna be a light month sponsor wise yeah
we're gonna we're not gonna mention new
names because no one's really at fault
yeah well except for wanting company but
never mind no no I mean it's it's just
like unfortunate circumstances and we
try to plan sponsors like month like we
have spots planned for December December
you know like we only have a few open
slots so this year left so we're usually
like super on top of things but then
just because of circumstance are our
next few videos are in it
there are next few weeks don't have any
sponsors which is rare for us like we we
sponsor pretty much every video which is
how we've been able to be full-time as a
smaller channel and we don't like trying
to like like like force and not forcing
but I try to like scramble to get any
last-minute sponsors on videos that are
going live soon because it's a big
process you want to make sure you're on
the same page you want to make sure that
you know everyone is cool with how
things are because we have very specific
requirements for the ads that we
integrate into our videos and if we
can't make sure all that's right well in
advance of when we go live it's just not
worth the stress you know I mean so yeah
another thing that's been on our minds
and it takes up it's a surprising amount
of time yeah so much time goes into
emails and coordinating and calls and
figuring it out and then when you have
to call something off or push something
it's just like Oh painful cuz we put in
days of work in the past like may not
days of work but like many hours I mean
it makes sense in a way like that's our
main income 60% of our income is from
sponsors and we do put a significant
amount of effort into that it's just an
effort that no one sees so I'm not gonna
lie I have I have been tempted before
cuz there are a lot of like bigger
channels that make enough off Adsense
that that's like covers all of their
bills and expenses and everything like a
lot of them only you know do a few
sponsored videos a year maybe you know
like the really big channels we have
thought of like bringing it down we have
thought about bringing it down but then
it's hard cuz like an opportunity comes
up and it's like a company we like and
it's like yeah yeah that's a great fit
um but but I have been tempted to that
but then on the other hand that puts so
much pressure on like the video
performance alone cuz usually sponsors
of course they like you have an expected
amount of views that they're paying for
but in most cases unless you're like
guaranteeing viewcount you still get
paid even if the video like doesn't do
as well as you expected yeah and so it's
a little bit more stable than only
relying on ads
and that helps with like that helps
contribute towards our work-life balance
a little bit like our the video we
released on the day that we're recording
this which is Friday the 16th so you
it'll be a few days ago for you guys
they can't foraging toy video cat forage
enjoyed video that video was something
we wanted to make we wanted to make that
for our cat we wanted to have a slightly
easier simpler video for us and for our
audience that you guys can do it too and
there's a lot of considerations that
went into that but one thing that we
thought is we're like this isn't gonna
go as big this isn't a crazy new idea or
anything like that and that's okay
we have you know these extra sources of
incomes that we're not relying just on
views yes it's okay to just have like a
normal performing video yeah so there's
still an important part of our business
Regt yes what am i saying well yeah it
has been a little bit crazy recently I
think it's just been so many in a row
and we're like oh and like we always
tried like anytime anything goes wrong
and like life or like in the
communication we have between each other
or communications we have with companies
or businesses we try to like okay what
lessons can we learn from that
like we did everything right with I
think all of these yeah it was just like
circumstances and I think that's a hard
thing about it because there's no
lessons we can learn there's nothing
that we can like take from this and
apply to make future things better it's
just like it's kind of been bad luck for
all three I think the main lesson
learned is is kind of a more general
lesson and it's just like being okay
with rolling with the punches punches
punches punches roll with the punches
when that happens yeah and I think that
like one it would have been okay to it
would have been okay but I think the
third one was like the straw that broke
my back I'm a camel I have a camel and
that's job broke my back I noticed like
now yeah and not that it really broke my
back I mean it's fine we're fine it's
just frustrating when you put in the
work and then like
nothing comes of it yeah and I mean you
know we are trying to turn it to our own
advantage and we're trying to advertise
for ourselves we're trying to advertise
our patreon and our you know gaming
channel and maybe one day in the future
we'll do another push for the podcast so
yeah trying to turn it around but it has
been like whoo-hoo but speaking of
turning things around transition time
into the next thing I wanted to talk
about finishing products that we are
projects that we just never got around
to finishing we're trying to like fully
wrap things up because as you guys know
you know we you know we make these
videos we have the final product but
after that in the past we've kind of
just been running off to the next
project we like literally like wrap
everything up we finished the video and
then we start the next one and we never
like like I'll give some examples the
resin knives we made we made those
knives we got the finish sauce and we
set them on a shelf and they're sitting
there very sad yeah yeah for the entire
garage project we cleaned up most of the
garage but then we have like piles of
stuff we still need to decide like what
to do with or where to organize them or
yeah stuff like that since I just passed
the garage so there's a lot of things
like that that we just haven't taken
care of because of the pace we're trying
to set because we're trying to get ahead
but leaving those broken bits of
projects behind kind of like bothered us
us at the same time that it like we're
getting ahead but also this bothers us
so we've been trying to take the time to
like fully wrap up project so I made a
little display stand for the knives that
we can put on our back wall or we can
hang it on a wall and it can be like
part of our story moving forward I've
been kind of chipping away at that pile
of stuff left over from the garage
mainly while Caitlin added so we're
still kind of like dual paths in between
a main priority project and like
catching up with the past but we do that
a lot like well film and then I'll edit
and you'll work on like the
miscellaneous to-do items that have
built up yeah yeah
oh man speaking of the knife video guys
when we launched the knife video we
go today YouTube was experiencing a
glitch where it didn't understand it
wasn't counting real-time views properly
and that freaked us and in the YouTube
back end there's a thing you can see on
your like dashboard for videos and it
tells you the performance of the video
you just released compared to the last
ten so it'll say like in the first hour
your video got two thousand views and
it'll say what all the other videos the
past ten videos got in their first hour
and it'll rank them so you'll see like
although some got two thousand but
everything else was like over three
thousand so this one sucks in comparison
so it's like the cat video that we
released today you know it launched at
number eight that's okay you know it was
a slightly less ambitious project not
that was less ambition it was like a
slightly smaller project it's not as
like what that's mind blowing it's not
as mind-blowing as resinize where we put
so much time and effort into the resin
Ives we wanted that to be like a little
bit of our hero project to kind of pick
up our numbers get our views up kind of
like show what we're capable of if we
put more time in and we have more time
and we launched it and it was at number
ten number ten is bad tens bad like bad
bad and everyone's like ranking is
different you know if all of your videos
have been like really close together
performance wise oh yeah you know it can
be one or it can be ten and it can still
be like a good video um we kind of have
like our one in two spots are usually
significantly far ahead and then three
through eight are kind of our middles
and anywhere in there is so good and
then like nine and ten are like
significantly lower
well cause like as you grow as a channel
as you get more subscribers and as you
get more reach hopefully you stay in
like that top one two three four five
six slot and you keep on growing but if
you keep on launching videos and they go
worse and worse worse worse and worse
than like that like is this an indicator
of the channel health a little bit yeah
so so a video that we expected to do
like really well for our channel being
number ten the knife video we were like
and we kind of do YouTube like YouTube
Twitter had said that the real-time
analytics are funky and but I bought the
same time we didn't know how funky and
we didn't know like if it was affecting
our channel or what-have-you
so we are freaking out eventually
texting other people some of our youtube
friends were like hey this is weird for
you too so like what's what's crazy
though is now that the real time data is
fixed and it's like archives and
everything when we launched this video
we saw the corrected real time for the
knife for the knife and when we launched
it it really was at 3 yeah it was doing
well but we were just freaking out
because we thought it was launching at
10 yeah it was actually three and then
it worked its way up to two and it's
been it to which is really good yeah so
we're freaking out but you know what
that just shows the blessing and curse
of real-time feedback so so I mean it's
interesting this is our lives we live
this a lot and I'm not sure how much you
guys are gonna relate cuz I know that
you know I'm not sure looking backwards
how much I paid attention to the likes
and hearts of my Instagram pose do you
remember that I think I paid attention
somewhat like so back when we just had
like personal personal ones yeah notice
our friends and family I think a little
bit but I also feel like like back then
I didn't follow any Instagram
influencers I followed I think a couple
cat Instagram pages
oh yeah but I wasn't following any
influencers or celebrities or anything
that like that you couldn't follow my
friends yeah you know so it was just
like you know I would post a photo get
like 12 likes and I'm like yeah that's
fine whatever you know like because it's
not a race when you're just using it for
personal it's not a race yes I don't I
don't remember caring at all either like
I would be more the thing that I got
into more with social media because I
was like the picture taker of the friend
group yeah and so it was actually more
for Facebook because you know Instagram
is like one pick
every so often you know one picture a
day or whatever and now now you could do
carousels but back before we started the
channel I don't think you could do
carousels so like for a gallery the only
places that send it or share it was
Facebook and so I would be more into
like posting pictures and then reading
all my friends comments about all the
things you were the archiver I was the
archiver yeah and so I like seeing
everyone's comments about like the
photos from that thing we did last night
or whatever so it's kind of just like
this you know you you document and
people comment and likes but well you
have all the comments you need now on
three channels yeah what about you
something you paid attention to I think
that I might have paid attention to it
like a tiny bit on Facebook but also
like sometimes I would try to be funny
you know so I think that if you're
sharing just for sharing that's one
thing but if you're sharing with like an
intent that people react then you do
care a little bit more you know that's
true yeah I would care more when like I
colored my hair or something picture I
like to say people liked her like if I
had just made a terrible mistake
but I mean I like we don't we don't go
so far even now I know that a lot of
people who are doing with social media
they will publish a photo and they'll
look at how good it's doing for the
first like ten minutes and if it's not
doing well they'll just delete it or
they'll post something different because
like that like they care about their
numbers they want to keep their like
average numbers up and if they post like
what they think of as a dud then then
they're like they don't want that on
their profile because some people who
are just doing Instagram they get paid
based on like how well things perform
that's so interesting you know yeah I
didn't think about I guess cuz like you
know our main content is a YouTube video
yeah and there's no like deleting that
it would yeah I just I mean it'd have to
be really just like terrible in some way
to make you delete it
well blow so some of our videos that
didn't do great when we first launched
they pick up later but Instagram things
don't have like negative
do not have a life it's like they kind
of have like well they're more
disposable they're like fruit flies
24-hour yeah science yeah yeah yeah so I
think part of the strategy for the
Instagram thing is you know you you
people vote by like when they see your
your post on Instagram if you scroll
past it that's kind of like a Down vote
if you like it that's enough vote and if
you like it in comment then instagrams
like ooh this one is doing well and
depending on how the post does it'll go
out to a broader audience and I think
that you only get like a certain number
of impressions per day or something like
that before you're judged it's kind of
interesting and I mean we can kind of
tell also it's like when we share a post
within 10-15 minutes we'll know if it's
going to do well or not primary it's not
a primary thing but I guess like I guess
yeah there is a difference between like
posting something when it's when it is
your primary there's different levels
like when it's your primary YouTube we
really care about YouTube for me on
Instagram we don't as much because it's
a secondary thing it's not the main
that's interesting and if Instagram was
our main we probably would care a lot
more and would put like you know would
try to play the game more or whatever it
is yeah
that's interesting it's it's always
interesting when I see we're getting
kind of off topic but um when I see
people who we follow who are primarily
instagramers that are like really big on
Instagram but then they start at YouTube
mm-hmm and it's so interesting because
it's like there isn't a super high
turnover if there's not a huge yeah
there's not a huge yeah turnover of
followers I mean there's such different
platforms if someone is following you
because you post pretty pictures or like
funny cat pictures or whatever it is
whatever you know no judgement all
things are good but like if they're
following you on Instagram for one thing
like there's really no parallels between
Instagram and Facebook really
you mean streaming YouTube Instagram and
you
really I mean unless like every one of
your posts is like a long video then
then maybe you might transition over
fairly nicely like if you're if your
Instagram page was you doing like
woodworking and projects and you had
like a mix of personality and like
making and stuff like that and ever
never everyone was always like I wish
your videos were longer I would watch
them if they were longer and then you
start doing longer videos which is what
they wanted great but if all they want
are like cool pictures and all of a
sudden you start at YouTube channel how
much about yeah crossover is there like
I don't know similarity I do think the
maker community it probably is a higher
chance for crossover yeah I was like I
feel like typically if you're following
like a woodworking Instagram like you're
relatively interested in how things are
put together yeah and the process make
sense but if you think about most
Instagram influencers they're not
they're not woodworkers yeah you know
it's like Instagram models there isn't
as much well there still is a process
behind it but like making videos about
that process can't be as big videos have
to be about the process like if you're
an Instagram model you could do vlogs
yeah you could Eve logs but but like but
it would make sense if you're an
Instagram model that wrote very
interesting long paragraphs and people
liked you for the store you told with
the photos but if all they wanted were
the photos yeah then the conversion
might not be great the point I guess we
were trying to make earlier on is that
like even if you're not playing the
Instagram or social media or YouTube or
whatever game I do think this is
something that affects people more and
more and I think it didn't like super
affect us personally beforehand but I
think there are a lot of people like we
even have friends that like they gotta
take a picture for the gram every day
yeah you know what I mean yeah and it's
like oh yeah well I guess I should take
a picture too oops
yeah I guess I was take a picture while
I'm doing this thing how is it different
than school because at school you kind
of got graded on your work not let it
but but it wasn't instant and like and
it it wasn't that important well no it's
important schools very important as long
as you're getting like decent grades you
know I
different because I think it's a very
it's one facet of your life and it's
very controllable
it's very controllable it's not like a
group of people judging you it's not
like your peers you know it'll be like
it's like if you went up to sing it in
front of an audience and as you saying
they started putting up scorecards yeah
as you were singing yeah that's it
because we're still doing it we're still
making it and like as we're making it
we're getting feedback on everything
we've done sorta but I mean like the
video we're not like making screaming
yeah that's more like screaming okay
yeah you're right but I just I do think
it is interesting because like as
opposed to most other types of jobs and
stuff where you know what back when I
was doing graphic design I might work on
a design send it off to the client I
find out days later if they like it or
not it's yeah I don't know it's just
different well but also with you know
like your example with the client you do
a design you send it off a few days
later you get it back but the thing is
you have a chance to change that or fix
that if they're not happy with it it's
not permanent yes in a way but with with
putting content out there on YouTube it
kind of is fairly permanent yeah and
it's interesting because with real-time
feedback the good thing about it is you
can make changes quickly yeah you're
right we can we can flex and shift like
BAM
one example is you know we in some
videos we tested giving the supervisor a
computerized voice which we find
hilarious and then there is some a lot
of people liked it and then there's some
people that found it deeply disturbing
we're like okay in the next couple
videos we we won't do it and we'll see
like do people yeah do people miss it or
are there people saying oh I'm so glad
you removed that creepy supervisor voice
and if people miss it then maybe we'll
bring it back and people have commented
saying that they miss the voice so we're
like okay we can bring it back more
people commented we missed the voice now
that it's gone then people commented
that voice is weird when it was there so
the creepy voices habits yeah but I
guess that's just one example of like
well I think the big contrast we can
draw is with a with a TV show so a TV
show the entire thing is planned
scripted shot edited completed
everything is done that's a better
example than like my graphic design exam
yeah and and and once it's all done it's
pretty much done and when you go to
launch it you just play the episodes in
order or a week apart and I'm not I'm
pretty sure that like people aren't
going back to the edits and recutting
and re doing things I mean if there are
any people who are familiar with TV show
productions let us know but I'm pretty
sure it would have to be like some kind
of scandal or something yeah something
big something big
yeah cause that cuz that that'd be very
expensive but like I'm pretty sure like
when when they were shooting friends the
scripted TV show there's nothing really
like super controversial in there that
they kind of like write the script for
the entire season they bring the actors
in they film it all the actors go away
it goes to the editors editors edit it
all and they get sent to the yeah but
you won't back until everything's the
entire season is done yeah so it's like
if like at the very beginning of the
hike let's say that it like you were
doing like a competition cooking show
and you're like catchphrase whenever
you're done was bobbing and like like
use like the very first time you had a
success you start going bobbing I know
you know that the entire season and then
and then like the very first time it
comes online everyone ridicules you for
Bing and you know that the rest of the
season it's just gonna be some things
baby all the time all the things all the
time and you can't change that
you suck yeah so I guess that's like
that the downside of being in a
situation like traditional media where
you can't change it yeah it's like in a
way it's like you've done it's decided
there's no stressing that's it yeah it's
out of your control
yeah whereas like when you are in
something like social media you kind of
obsess over it all the time and you can
second-guess up to the very last minute
which even this morning I was like
should I had more information in the
video about what a cat foraging toy is
like do we need to provide more
background on on what that even means
then show some more examples maybe I'll
do like a voiceover real quick and it's
like no no it's an hour before lunch we
can't do that
and it's like yeah like you can change
up until the last minute it's a good
it's a blessing it's a curse yeah yeah
do you think it's a good it's like I was
gonna say it's a good thing it's a bad
thing and midway through I changed it
where's our hard can you see your shirt
no it's not really showing up on the
camera this one's an extra subtle one
Evans wearing awards a heart chart it
was a test print there's a Tuscan yeah
than the real ones it's a little extra
subtle yes anyways people listening
really which means we should probably
move to our game today we're gonna be
playing a fail tank why didn't call it
bell tank cause it's like Shark Tank but
I don't know most of mine are good I
think mine are pretty good win tank win
tank tank tank the tank the tank tank
anyways this is a game we played earlier
on in the podcast it's inspired by a
game well I was gonna say well yeah and
sorry by shark tank but also Jenna and
Julian played their own version of shark
tank on the Jenna Julian podcast yes we
thought it seemed really fun but anyways
we pitch product ideas to each other
judge them shark good to meet you
good to meet you sir my name is my name
is Steve so Steve my name is Steve I
come to you today to pitch an idea pitch
I call it model craft is it a modeling
clay no what it is is there's a 3d
modeling software that anyone can play
now what you do is you build things in
Minecraft you acts for them as STL's and
you can print them on your 3d printer
okay that's actually like pretty awesome
right cuz like you can like words
it'll be so cool cuz in creative mode we
haven't done creative mode yet but you
can like fly around you can create
things and I think it'd be cool to like
you can choose do you want to smooth
everything out like smooth the pixels or
do you want to leave things sharp and
like precise you know and you can even
like say like this area over there make
that like smooth that out like if you do
a circle you can like smooth it out but
if you want to leave the edges edgy you
can like leave them edgy that's actually
like a really good idea yeah it's crazy
and then you can even like do two
different block colors to do like split
the object in half or do like
multicolored
fill them into printing or whatever oh
that's extra fancy extra fancy
but I think that like someone could
legit make a plugin for Minecraft Java
so you can model yeah and you can just
like walk around it and everything I
think that'd be so cool to like like
what if you built a castle and then you
printed it that'd be pretty cool or a
cat statue I just want a creeper oh I
didn't just build a giant statue of a
creeper in Minecraft you just print the
creeper I feel you should have access to
oh I need $6,000 definitely get it yeah
[Applause]
half a million dollars oh well yeah it's
for $6,000 yeah oh okay if it's for your
idea I'm the shark now my name is patty
hi patty
my name is Steve I have six thousand
dollars now I'm a shark oh do you
let's see that's here it's called pop
hands is it pants for your cat
no but related
it's it's really um padding that goes in
your pants it's adjustable there there
are inner pockets in the pants and you
can adjust the padding and put the
padding in certain spots because you
know when your cat jumps in your lap
there's always a certain way they like
to sit in your lap supervisor likes to
have her head on the left side of my lap
meaning her claws are always in the same
spot on my thigh and when cats like purr
and our content sometimes they like make
bread you know they need poked holes
inside of you through my leggings and I
just have a series of tiny holes in the
same spot on my leg it's just gonna all
turn into scar tissue so if you have pop
pants fall pants popping its pads that
you put in your pants and you can adjust
as needed depending on your cat and it
protects you how much money do you need
oh it's cheap it's only half a million
no six thousand dollars you know what
why do you need half a million dollars
for an idea that simple this just
marketing marketing smart that's where
the cost is but that's where the profits
are - okay I'll take a loan you know
what I hear YouTube influencers you know
YouTube content creators that is where
the best bang for your buck yeah we
should look at people who have recently
done cat projects that's a good idea
good idea good idea Patti thanks Steve
let's give a name straight it would be
great though it's like I wonder if you
could just do that now sometime stuff it
in your pants because you're an elegant
lady well you need a fashion inserts cuz
like would ya always wear the same pants
or would it just be like an insert that
you can put in any pants I think idea I
came up with it what you do is you have
strong magnets at the top and the bottom
and then you just like slip them into
your pants and you put magnets on the
outside that'll hold it in position you
can't you can't do that because then the
cat's gonna avoid the magnets Oh
but like the rama's will be high up and
oh like high up high up above and below
then you can like attach to any parents
yeah that's a good idea I'm glad
I'm glad we went into this deal together
Steve okay 50/50 split right 49 51 okay
I'm glad you gave me okay okay fatties
fall pants she let's check on okay third
Jake yes well we had to finalize the
profit split yeah that's a good deal
okay so the next invention that Steve
had Steve the master no no we we took
that half a million dollars and we made
it to a million now so you know we we're
doing good Poppins is already like on
its way Marlo Kraft is also but it's a
smaller success there's a nice product
but this is a large a large thing so how
much of the US people have cats US
people cats buff lots and and there's a
global market too for the cat master
3000 it's a big hamster wheel for a cap
those already exist you might say yes
but not a cat wheel like this one what
makes you different
this one has a gear that spins as the
cat runs the gear spin and it slowly
spins thing and that thing dispenses
food oh so it's like a motivator
it's a motivator workout and eat at the
same time yeah and like you know in the
beginning you'll have you know food
elsewhere but over time the cat master
3000 can become their only source of
food and they will be fine fit felines
so how do they eat it like in there
because there's just a big rolling ball
it drops next to them so they're running
right here it spins a little like
feeding thing it drops into a bowl more
like an inner ball within the ball that
stays upright like a gyroscope those are
not a hamster ball it's a hamster wheel
it's a big wheel it's a big wheel that
spins round like a waterwheel you know
they would like get off of it and eat
and then they can run for some more yeah
and I think they should even disperse it
like I think that what it does is it's
like a you know the twirly pasta shape
so what it is is like it'll drop in like
five or six pail
and then when it dispenses it dispenses
all five or six at once hmm so it's like
here's your snack break everything's
cool and like you know you can eat for a
while they can run for a while too until
they hear that yeah and you know what
I'm like hop off for just one treat you
know you wanna like have like a meal you
know and I'd be pretty cool that's a
pretty man we've just been having lots
of really good ideas on this I mean all
the two million dollars you've earned
from take my money all right perfect
51 50 49 split good good Jake good job
okay what's your next idea now that
we're like multimillionaires yeah we're
really cornering the cat market order in
the cat market okay you're really
inspiring confidence there Patti it's
called the booty rumbler oh I like here
you go okay
it's like booties it's a toilet seat but
massager how big is this thing hey how
do you clean it it fits on on the
outside like on the top of a toilet seat
what's the purpose it vibrates you're
crazy
okay okay hear me out okay five times
you are in the restroom for an extended
period of time has your butt ever fallen
asleep millions of Americans have their
butts fall asleep good job you save the
world thank you I save the butts you say
the Box how much money do you need oh
this one's got some light it's pretty
technical so I need a billion five
million okay cool good job we'll make it
work but yeah but rumbler a lot of
people use a rumble master yeah though
the name of the name we can work on a
lot of people their their personal me
time is in the restroom the butt master
5000 this is a good one I wonder if it
would actually prevent your legs from
falling asleep
I might some rumbles yeah yeah or like
after a certain amount of time it'll
like say
hey we know you're done so after the
rumble poop 5000 works still in progress
and now I present to you the poor master
5000 yes everything's a master with a
name huh and I'm sorry I'd master with a
number Wow so what's it called again
what's a Klingon the poor master
5000 Master is this resin pouring
related I like guessing
it's it's similar ish but it's actually
acrylic because resin was too hard to
clean up so what it is is do you like
acrylic art I do
but is it too hard to get the pour
precise and the right amount so hard so
hard and do you want to sell a whole
bunch with like a pattern you know makes
a good art piece okay it's a CMC
controlled flow master 5000 you plan on
selling a whole bunch of these seems
very nice and expensive what you do is
you load the poor cylinders up with
different colored acrylic paints and
you've program in different patterns and
it disperses the flow acrylic in the
patterns can I can I have a constructive
criticism that maybe we can go into
business together
yes I'm thinking a low-tech version
where you have you have you seen where
people take like a colander they put it
upside down and they pour through the
holes so that you can make like a
pattern and everything's evenly spaced
hmm
so the port like on the top the colander
it'll go through the holes stuff like
that where it's just like different
shaped domes or like raised plastic
pieces a 3d printed you can just three
to play all different types of shapes
make new patterns but that's assuming
you're assuming someone has a CNC or has
a 3d printer I knows how to do that just
sell deposit plastic piece yeah so you
consult kits yeah of like these
different things that are patterns that
work really well for a full cups cool
things to pour over that make different
shapes make different patterns you could
get like a fancy add-on where they can
like spin it mmm
you know stuff like that yeah you could
totally you could totally do that yeah
that would be cheaper because I was
thinking like
if you want to do art like that but you
you you like came up with like a cool if
you stuff you do like black from the top
down and then you do a layer of blue on
top in a few places and then like a
scraper arm comes in and scrapes in a
certain way it makes a cool night scape
or something I was thinking like you do
like repeatable designs they're all
unique but you can like make them really
yes so that's more of like a b2b that's
business-to-business you're you're
selling to someone who is making them to
sell yeah cuz you don't need to make
that many like repeated yeah the b2b
product not to be this thing an abuse II
yeah yeah because yeah yeah I was
thinking like it would be nice but you
could probably sell a couple hundred to
people who like to make and sell art
another thing you know the art in hotels
that sometimes sucks often often
wouldn't it be way cooler if they were
like acrylic art and they were all
unique but there are still there they're
able to be mass-produced but they're all
still unique yeah they'll be cool you
know that'd be cool but I feel like if
you're gonna do that idea I'm just gonna
run with my own idea of the little
individual plastic pieces that I can saw
on it let's let's do let's start the
company poor master and we're gonna have
the CNC 5900 yeah no but yours is like
the poor master kit you know for the DIY
ours out there so it's like two tiers
you know so it's like we have some it's
like hey the poor masters 6000 I
upgraded it it's the 6000 now because
it's fancier because it has an arm the
5000 doesn't have the arm the 6000 has
the arm it's like the scraper arm makes
the headlines
it makes the rounds on the news you know
we're on the Today Show you know like
with the people doing it and everything
and we're like this is really cool it
could do all the stuff but if you want
to do yourself you can pick up this kit
for $5.99 plus tax and three easy
payments $5.99 something like that
business together they are sure about
yours but like I want to do mine I feel
like I can't do it unless we're in
business
okay good job we're billionaires now
pretty much I mean we just need to wait
a little bit I'll just wait till my last
idea okay
let's break the bank let's break the
internet it's called fate
babe oh wait is it for beards that's one
news okay so it's a bib that you attach
over your ears that catches the food
right there so it doesn't know oh okay
proceed I see but similar so it's
actually for a beard it's for its it's
for beard trimming oh also for makeup
fallout which is something you might not
be as familiar with but when you're
applying your makeup all especially
powder makeup all the little like powder
gets on your dress or something it gets
on your shirt it gets in the sink beard
hair is good on your shirt get on your
sink and what if you're getting ready
what if like you're getting ready for a
night out you're already all dressed
maybe you need to touch up your makeup
you don't want to like get it on your
dress yeah you put on on the face bib
yeah it's a bib for things that fall off
your face and doesn't hang off of your
ears no I was thinking more around the
neck around the neck yes seems more
comfortable yeah yeah you get that
probably makes more sense yeah just kind
of like a trash can so it's like it's
like waited on the back and then it's
like a trash can in front yeah it's not
maybe not as big as a trash can cuz like
beard hair is kind of like okay it's as
big as a trash can but it's lightweight
it's like a very small thin trash can
yeah but not as it's deep yeah super
lightweight super got it inserts so you
can quickly take it out you can quickly
take it out dump it yeah put it back in
exactly I'm in how much money do you
need Japanese no idea it's a pretty
simple idea but again I feel like
marketing BAM I could do two million
million okay good yeah we're definitely
gonna reach out to like all the
Instagram models boy and girl yeah and
like get some fancy in person like in
you shot it'll be really glamorous oh
yeah company oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
so we'll have like a gold a silver yes
the classic colors cuz it's expensive
because you're a fancy person if you
have this yeah well you're a fancy
person because you don't have makeup on
your shirt yeah your definition of a
hair on your shirt mm-hm
Wow okay you know what like we don't we
joke but some of these ideas are really
yeah some are questionable like the
booty run black huh
you know what the booty rumbler I didn't
see it at first but now I see now you
see my vision but I want to be built
into this seat itself so it's like maybe
it's like a seat replacement replacement
yeah because I want to be easy to clean
but I want it to be something that you
could use with your existing bathroom
yeah
you know you don't don't no problem
you're gonna have to like plug it into a
wall and that's like power right near
water
but motors take a lot of energy you know
won't worry about that the technical
team can worry about the logistics
engineer's come up with like a
possibility what you would do nothing
you wouldn't know anything about that
would you
no I wouldn't know anything about that
except for every single day of my past
life Oh guys well this was really fun
I'm glad we did the shark tank again
like that was fun to bring it back that
was fun all right guys well update
update what's that oh yeah I think oh
yeah first and then update guys have you
ever wanted a computer this as small as
your pocket I did and I got one look at
that look at this this well anyone who
can't see this who's just listening to
audio it's about like it's about the
size of like a mini I like the tiny iPad
air or something like that it's but it's
a full computer full computer it has
Windows 10 it has 16 gigabytes of RAM it
has an i7 processor it has half a
terabyte of hard drive space you can run
Photoshop on it Photoshop on it it has a
full size USB 3 port it has a USB C port
for charging and everything that the USB
C port has I mean this has this has
better ports than the iPad I think
because it has USB C well an iPad also
isn't a computer oh sorry sorry oh the
UM MacBook Air oh the Mac hair only has
two USB sees this has
USB normal USB 3.0 you know that it's so
great and I don't want to get into all
the things but I have been wanting one
of these computers for a long time for
like seven years ten my whole life
basically basically I mean I you know
though I got the Palm Pilots when they
first came out I loved at those and I
always just loved small computers and
I've always wanted one that's like as
small as you can get and I think that
this size right here is as small as you
can get and it still be a functional
computer there are some compromises like
the keyboard was has been shifted a
little bit around and everything you
should maybe say like what brand it is
or what it's called oh yeah this is
calling it tiny computer this is the one
netbook one mix 3s Platinum I got the
really expensive one I got the fancy one
you can get like more budget ones that
have an atom processor and don't have as
much RAM and don't doesn't have as big
of a hard drive but I want to use this
as like my main travel computer it's
gonna save space it's gonna save time
it's gonna save weight and I can fit it
in tiny backpack now so like this could
fit into your backpack Caitlyn you're
like baby back it's just so cool and it
just makes me happy happening having it
and yeah that's pretty much it
I've been wanting this and like I've
talked about it to Caitlyn way more than
she needed to hear about it we'd go on
walks and I'm a Caitlyn I found a new
potential computer and like I'd get so
hyped for it so much like up until this
point there's always like some
disqualifying factor it just didn't have
it just didn't have all of the things
that I wanted and or it was like a
little bit too big or a little bit too
small and I think this is the perfect
compromise between all of the different
things so I'm just like I just I'm just
relieved one of my bucket list items has
been taken care of owning a tiny
computer that actually functions and you
can do stuff on I think in the future
they'll
able to have like an like even more they
can fit even more into something this
size and I'm just excited that like this
is the beginning of the tiny computer
evolution I'm joking not really ok good
what is your thing of the week mine's
very low-tech but it's it's actually
this isn't a new thing for us but I was
using it recently and we use it all the
time because we make a lot of pasta but
you know normally when you make pasta
you have to pull out like the big
colander and put it in your sink
speaking of calendars we're talking
about calendars earlier anyways ah yeah
yeah you do like take out the big bulky
calendar and put it in your sink and
it's like a whole big other thing you
have to wash when your dishes and colors
are not easy to wash yeah they're not
easy to wash with all the holes and
they're just big and bulky and take up a
lot of space on your drying rack anyways
so my thing of the week is this little I
don't even know what you would call it
it's like a little hand reamer
it's like a handheld strainer but it's
meant to be held on the edge of a pot as
you're pouring stuff out of the pot and
there's little holes on it so instead of
having a colander then having to wash a
colander and store a big colander we
just bring the whole pasta pot over to
the sink we have I just hold this little
strainer onto the edge of it it's like a
little crescent moon shape and it just
kind of locks on to the side of it and
then you can pour it out the pasta stays
in the pan and the water pours out and
it's like so nice it doesn't take up any
more room than like a spatula yeah in
your drawer we don't even have a
colander yeah we used to we don't have
one anymore yeah cuz we just use this
all the time yeah we did have a colander
yeah and it didn't suck but it was fine
it was a good colander but it was just
like well another thing pain to clean if
you boiled the pasta in a pot you know
that you can pour the water out and your
pots big enough the colander might be
too small yeah yeah that's true we've
had like over spillage where the
colander fills up and then your pastas
falling in this thing so you just cooked
sad cuz then it's lost pasta that you
could have eaten
speaking of pasta I'm getting hungry
yeah that's a good thing of the week
that's something that we've we've we use
it's been using so much we love it
no one else I know you
is it and I'm like why don't you guys
say it's like a magic secret unlocked
ability yeah so we'll have links to both
of our thing of the week's yeah in the
show notes / video description as usual
and as a wrap-up item that I wanted to
address you know as we've mentioned
before we read all of your reviews on
iTunes and they usually make us very
happy but we got our first 1 star we did
I'm outraged someone who found us cuz I
think that you guys have been amazing
and you guys have pushed us to like Oh
ranking on the podcast charts you know
it's not it's not crazy high up there
but like you know we've gotten in the
50s 30s before on in iTunes for a
category and someone from like Oh a new
podcast have seen who are these people
why are they crazy so we have reached
someone outside of the circle so so it's
actually a good sign it's a good sign
but if you guys could kind of drown out
that one star overwhelm it overwhelm it
yes well thank you guys for spending
some of your time with us I hope you
have a wonderful day
and Williford seniors
[Music]